The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: To describe
the spatial history of London
in 45 minutes is impossible.
London has to be seen in the
light of a number of issues.
It's the greatest
open city in history.
I'm going to be interested
in the spatial development
of London from about 1750
onwards, the period which
we have demarcated as being
the advent of modernism.
Sit down.
London was first occupied
by the Romans in 43 AD.
And they stayed in
England until about 400
AD, a long period of time.
London never built great walls.
As I said in a previous
class, the walls in Europe
are widest on the east
and get distinctly less.
Paris rebuilt the walls a
number of times, as late
as the 19th century.
But the British, separated
from continental Europe,
never invested a great deal
in protecting the city.
The crossing of the River Thames
was towards the northeast--
that is, towards what is
now the city of London,
the business and most protected
original part of London.
The period post [INAUDIBLE]
can be characterized
by the application
of the British
of a number of contested
arenas of social life
and economic life.
Already in 1838, the
Chartist movement
agitated for the
Democratic use of the vote.
The first labor
unions were starting
to be originated in
the early 19th century.
Charged labor was
put out of business.
The origins of public housing--
the state never built
housing for people
except if there had to be
housed under poverty conditions.
Most of the cities
in pre-English Europe
relied on religious powers
and charity to house people.
There was no notion that the
public had any responsibility
for housing the population.
So at least amongst
the many innovations
that this period
endorses, one would
include the major,
major, major organization
of the state towards
environmental improvement,
taking care of
public sanitation,
the origin of welfare, state
health, building bylaws,
the emergence of
women's rights, the laws
against racial discrimination,
and the emergence
of the first--
I would call the modern
city-planning organization
with London County Council,
1889 to 1965, the most dramatic
state organization to
organize the application
of spatial and
social principles.
The London County Council--
one of the problems
about city planning
is that you need an organization
internal to the state
or to the city to maintain
the quality of work.
Outside consultants are OK.
Unlike architecture,
with outside consultants,
you can build a building.
City planning is a
continuous process
of adjustment, management
of public wealth
and private wealth.
And one of the biggest
problems of working
in many parts of the
world today, for me,
is to adjust the level
of work in relation
to the level of the
capacity of application.
There's no point in using
advanced levels of spatial
control in a city which cannot
maintain its application
and adjustment.
I'm just, at the moment, engaged
with the city of Abu Dhabi, who
wants some help making
a new strategic plan.
They want to do it without
outside consultants.
They want to do it through
their own internal labor force.
The real question is whether
they're going to be able to.
But that's an
ongoing discussion,
which I'm having with them.
London had already
established an enormous number
of characteristics of a
cultured and open city.
Shakespeare bought a
house in London in 1613.
He paid for it
through the profits
he made on theater
audiences in central London.
John Locke, in 1685--
1689, perhaps--
published a paper
arguing for the separation
of church and state.
It was really towards the
end of the 17th century.
London has maintained
itself as an open city.
2.6 million of the current
population of London
are foreign-born.
That's about 30% of the
population of London today
are foreign-born.
I think that's roughly
equivalent to Los Angeles.
I'm not sure about Los
Angeles, but forgive me.
I'm just guessing.
I should know, but I
don't know a great deal.
I read from the New York Times,
March the 4th, 2012, writing
about London.
Every month, some
young bureaucrat
in the Chinese
State Administration
of Foreign Exchange reaches
out to a trader in London
and buys or sells billions
worth of US treasury bonds.
London is the world's
largest market for dollars.
So if you think
about all the money
that's being paid by
the Chinese government,
it's paid to London.
London has remained the
central economic site
for a great deal of the
international world.
We thought, perhaps,
by looking at some
of the spatial attributes
from the two major disasters,
the fire of 1666 and the
plague epidemic of 1666--
no modern city has ever been
struck by two major disasters
so close to one another.
The Fire of London
was the greatest fire
the world had ever seen.
On the 1st of September,
1666, the wooden structures
close to the river,
to the docks,
exactly the same as
Chicago in the Chicago Fire
200 years later--
the mayor was
apparently unimpressed
when first called to the scene.
He expostulated, pish, a
woman might piss this out.
He woke up the next day
to find half the world
around him destroyed.
The fire interested
us less than the fact
that five days after the
flames had been controlled,
a young professor
of anatomy called
Christopher Wren, not yet
widely known as an architect,
approached the king with a plan.
The plan took no account
whatever of the medieval street
plan.
He superimposed his
grandiose vision
of wide avenues radiating
in straight lines
from the Royal Exchange.
On 13 September,
Charles II, the king,
issued a proclamation,
assuring the city that,
quote, "though
every man must not
be suffered to reap
whatever--" oh, I
don't want to read the quote.
Essentially, Wren
assumed that you
could socialize land and
change the form of a city
by imposing a new
spatial pattern on it.
The king said no, in
England, we respect
the ownership of
private property,
even if it's of a small scale.
And I will not
endorse a plan which
does not advocate the
maintenance of the rights
of my citizens to land.
There was another plan by John
Evelyn, which I'll show you.
Wren build an
enormous amount of--
in the post-fire era, he
built a number of churches.
And many of them is still there.
He, of course, built
St. Paul's Cathedral.
His clients didn't
like it very much.
In his latest,
1713, I think he was
begging them to pay his income.
So much for Wren.
The principle that
London would not
be subject to the
powers of the state
to change its
spatial pattern has
been central to the maintenance
of the form of London.
London doesn't
have large avenues.
It has one, perhaps.
Oxford Street is the old Roman
road from the east to the west.
It has no north-south road
except for Regent Street, which
we'll discuss a bit later.
It is the imposition of
a particular situation.
The second epidemic of
London was the plague.
But before the plague,
London's River Thames
had an underclass of
people who made a living
out of the filth of this river.
They were people
called bone pickers,
rag gatherers, pure finders,
dredgermen, mudlarks,
sewer hunters, dustmen, night
soil men, bunters, toshers,
shoremen.
If they had all formed
themselves into a union,
this London
underclass would have
been the fifth-largest
agglomeration of people
in all of England.
The consequences of
the river's water
being as polluted
as it was was only
established through the genius
of a man called John Snow.
Before that, the
outbreaks of cholera
were generally assumed to
be a condition of the air.
The miasmic theory of
cholera was prevalent.
London's Parliament had to
shut down one summer because
of the stench from the river.
But John Snow-- you
must read The Ghost Map.
Has anybody read the
book The Ghost Map?
Good for you.
I'm really using London as an
example of the transformation
of a 19th-century city
under extraordinary level
of commitment and skill.
Up till 1854, cholera was seen
as a disease borne by the air.
There'd been many
attempts to make
the process of draining your
body a little more elegant.
A water-flushing device
had been invented
in the late 16th century,
who installed a functioning
version for his godmother,
Queen Elizabeth.
The device didn't take on
until a watchmaker called
Albert Cummings
designed an improved
version of Herrington's design.
At the Great Exhibition of 1851,
an estimated 827,000 visitors
used them.
After that, the seated toilet
became much more common
in London.
According to one estimate,
the average London household
used 160 gallons of
water a day in 1850.
Thanks to the runaway
success of the water closet,
they were using 244
gallons per day.
Snow transformed the
world of cholera.
You have to read the book to
understand the Sherlock Holmes
genius with which this man
observed the situation, which
resulted in his finding
that cholera was carried
by a bacillus borne by water.
All of the improvement
in the seated toilet seat
simply meant that
more and more feces
were being poured into cesspools
because there was no sewage
system.
Imagine a city where there is
no sewage system, where there
are constant
outbreaks of cholera,
until one modest general
practitioner in the West End
comes up with the notion
that it's waterborne.
Such is the genius of British
endeavor at this time.
It took only seven years.
Yeah.
The most advanced and
elaborate sewage system
in the entire world was
largely operational by 1865.
Joseph Bazalgette, the
engineer, in six years
had constructed nearly
82 miles of sewage
using over 300 million
bricks and nearly a million
cubic yards of concrete.
The main--
All the sewage flowed
into the Thames,
which either remained
static or flowed,
eventually, out to the sea.
Bazalgette built two in the
north and one in the south.
This took all of the sewage
and water, wastewater,
and pumped or used elevation
to export it to the sea.
Around central London, he built
two embankments, the Chelsea
and the Victoria embankment
on the north and the Albert
embankment on the south.
This is one of the
biggest industrial feats
in human history.
The extraordinary thing is
that if you're in London
and you walk on the embankment,
you don't know anything
about what it's doing.
London advertises Big Ben
because you can see it.
The underground of
cities is impalpable.
This is an extraordinary example
of the genius, Sir Joseph
Paxton, who designed the
Crystal Palace, the Gardener.
He said, we in Britain solve
problems by common sense
and technology, not bombast.
I wonder what the American--
what a city like Boston would
build in six years, hardly
a sewage system.
The next issue again
starts with a disaster.
We want to examine the
transformation of land
in central London.
We start with a story.
Alexander, the nephew
of Mr. Hugh Audley,
died in the plague.
Mr. Audley was a
lawyer, a great leader.
He amassed a great legendary
wealth through dealings
with a court of wards, the
court which apportioned
lands forfeited to the Crown
when the owner couldn't
pay the fees.
Among his property rights
which he accumulated
was the Manor of Ebury, which
was swamps and farmsteads which
ran from the Thames River as
far north as the old Roman
road to Bath, Oxford Street.
So the West End of
London was a swamp.
It accrued into the
hands of this family.
Through a number of
generations, it passed down
to a woman called Mary Davis.
Mary Davis had needed money.
She arranged a marriage
to Lord Berkeley.
These were rural
establishments looking for land
in the center of the city.
Lord Berkeley--
Mary was only seven.
And their marriage arrangement
was made with the Berkeley's
10-year-old son.
But there was no money.
They couldn't raise an
additional 3,000 pounds.
The next marriage deal was
with Sir Thomas Grosvenor
at the age of 21.
Mary-- now 12--
was married in 1677.
Mary developed mental illness,
became a fanatic critic--
oh, Catholic, not a critic.
Surely some mental slip
from Catholic to critic.
They're selecting a pope.
I suppose that's on my mind.
Grosvenor died in 1700.
Mary was swept off to Europe
by a Roman Catholic priest
called Father Fenwick.
In Paris, Fenwick
drugged her, married her
to his elder brother,
Edward Fenwick.
In 1703, a court resolved
Fenwick versus Grosvenor.
The court favored
the Grosvenor family.
His son, Sir Richard, began to
develop the states of Mayfair,
Belgravia, Pimlico.
Mary's land plus the
Grosvenor's provincial estates
produced the largest fortune
in British hands, only second
to the royal family.
You should really be able
to answer this question.
Why are there no
railway stations
on the west side of London?
I've just told you the story.
Crown, crown, crown-- you
can look at your diagram.
The Grosvenor'
estates-- number five,
and these are number two--
as a block of land
impeded the development
of any railroad on the west.
London is encircled
by railroads,
four miles by
1-and-1/2-mile box.
There's a subway line
which runs along this box.
What's it called?
Who knows London?
Come on, you must know
something about the greatest
city in the world.
You're studying
urbanism, aren't you?
It's like me talking about
a classic case of pneumonia,
and you don't know what the
causes of pneumonia are.
The Circle Line.
Paddington, Euston, St.
Pancras, King's Cross,
Farringdon Street--
I think that's the one--
all linked to the industrial
heartland of England--
Victoria, Charing
Cross, Waterloo.
All link to South Africa, and
India, and the United States.
Some of these stations
on here link to Europe.
There are no
stations on this arc.
Now you know why.
The combination of land between
the Crown and the Westminster--
Duke of Westminster is
probably the highest ranking
in the British aristocracy.
The Grosvenors became
the Duke of Westminster.
OK.
I made my point.
It's a battle.
It also advances the
notion that the combination
of rural land and
urban land is required
to produce great wealth--
at least, at this time, it was.
Raymond Williams is correct
in his book The Country
and the City in making
the point that it
is a combination of
the two that produced
the shape of
contemporary England.
The second land story
deals with the fact
that the center of London
consisted, to the most part,
of land occupied by aristocracy.
Large portions of land--
the Bedfords, the Duke
of Bedford, for instance,
occupied large portions of land.
What emerged as a result
of economic growth
was the emergence-- and Marx
makes a classical reference
to the emergence of the middle
class of the bourgeoisie.
It has major economic factors.
So valuable did the
land become that it
had to be transformed into
sales to the middle class
or the upper-middle class.
So each of these states was
subdivided systematically.
Where was the first?
These subdivided estates
characteristically
have a residential--
or residential in nature, have a
central public, or semi-public,
or private square in the center.
And this animates the
whole spatial pattern
of central London,
at least most of it
to the west of Regent Street.
This is the only
city in the world
which has used
residential construction
to build its center.
The city was always
off to the east.
This is land which was available
just through the subdivision
of property.
Again, Rasmussen points out that
these subdivisions generally
were little towns in themselves.
It was the manor house,
which faced north.
There's sometimes more
than one manor house.
The housing was
generally occupied
by one family per unit, as
opposed to the boulevard
house of Paris, where every
floor was a separate housing
entity--
which, again, is one
of the many reasons
why London is about one-third
of the density of Paris.
The second has to do with the
transportation system, which
we'll talk about in a minute.
Why do you think the rest
of the world never followed
the British pattern
of subdividing land
in a systematic way for housing?
Stupid.
Why didn't the British impose
a system residential spatial
organization as interesting
and as articulate
as the British did for London?
I don't know how to
answer the question.
Ideas don't seem to spread
all that well, good ideas.
And of course, there
are many problems
with the fact that you're
subdividing land only
for another class
of people who can
pay the economic rent
through the leasehold system
of the subdivided estates.
The extraordinary notion
of using a building--
there are 151 residential
squares in western London,
77 between 1800 and 1850,
but starting in 1631
with one which is famous
for other reasons.
Its name is Covent Garden.
Why is it called Covent Garden?
How do you know
nothing about London.
You need, really,
to spend some time
in London learning about
how this great city got
to be put together.
Henry VIII didn't
like Catholicism.
So he closed the convents.
The convent which
became Covent Garden
was handed over to the
Bedford family, who employed
the great British architect.
Who was the greatest British
architect in the 17th century?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Hmm?
Inigo Jones.
Do you know the
name Inigo Jones?
You should know them
if you've studied
the history of architecture.
Mind you, the history
of architecture
is so badly taught that I'm
not surprised that nobody
knows the name of Inigo Jones.
Inigo Jones is an interesting
man in his own right.
Historians have often
thought that the term
Inigo came from the
fact that he was Welsh.
It turns out that recent history
has found that he actually
traveled to India.
And he was probably a
homosexual taken to India
by one of the aristocracy.
And the drawings of
him done in India,
which make his life a little
more complex, and perhaps
a little more interesting.
Anyway, he built a church,
St. Martin's in the Field,
as the main component
of the square.
The rest of the
square was empty.
There was some residential
accommodation in arcades,
which Jones designed.
But the center became a market,
became the famous market
and developed into Covent
Garden, which the great opera
house of Covent Garden--
I don't know if there's any
connection between an opera
house and an
agricultural market,
but the British seem to
do these strange things.
Perhaps the market
produced a number
of people who sang and
became an opera company--
so history's adjacency,
perhaps, produces.
What more can I say other
than to look with you
at some of these subdivisions?
I've given you, in the
handout on the first page--
if I remember correctly--
the landholdings.
Are they numbered?
Number five is the
Grosvenor land.
And number two is the Crown.
On the diagram above that,
it's got a lot of stuff on it.
It's rather complicated.
But essentially, starting
in 1631, Covent Garden,
you see a slow growth
of subdivisions
of these big estates.
And with the--
Sir John Summerson was
called the great period
in London building,
from about 1730
to 1800-and-so, the
Georgian period.
It's interesting
that these buildings,
these new residential
armatures to the squares,
were built according
to strict rules.
One of the reasons for
the care for maintenance
of these subdivided
estates is not only
because the land was expensive
but because one of the changes
that the British land
policy adopted, switching
from freehold to leasehold.
Royal land could never be sold.
Freehold land was
given by the king
to a client who had served
the king or queen admirably.
No resolution of
that was possible
until Parliament, realizing
the economic advantages
of this land and the
emergence of an economic class
of private buyers, decided
to pass a revision which
is called leasehold, which
meant that you were allowed,
as a royal aristocrat, to
subdivide your land over
long and lease it to somebody
for a long period of time--
I mean, 90 years, 100 years.
Summerson, I think,
argues that in order
to maintain the quality
of the property,
attention had to be paid to
the design of the buildings
and the quality of
the maintenance.
I'm not sure about that.
So it's a bit foggy as to
whether the leasehold system
doesn't automatically imply a
good maintenance of property.
The diagram below, you
can see number two,
which is where Buckingham
Palace is now--
two stretching all
the way to the river,
two stretching up
to Regent's Park,
which we'll talk
about in a minute,
and number five
stretching roughly
from the river, very
close to number two,
all the way up to Oxford
Street, which is--
well, I don't know if it's
exactly Oxford Street,
but in the proximity
of Oxford Street.
These diagrams show
the subdivision of two
of the estates.
The Matrix of Comparative
Orders argument
is from an MIT thesis which
argues that West London
suggests an intermediate order.
A textural order, such as
Rome, Parma, Delhi, Paris,
and so on the left, and the
intermediate order of West
London, and monumental orders,
and the intermediate order
of another kind
in Bath and so on.
You can read this and
work it out yourself.
Residential squares
generally had
gardens in the center space.
In first, gardens
were private gardens.
You inserted in the center
of the residential space
a garden, which was gated.
This was a strange idea, to
insert in the public domain
a private-only use.
The British never had
large gardens of their own.
So in some sense, it was
a formal substitution
of a private garden into
a communal private garden,
a very interesting idea.
Although, as time
passed, this idea passed,
and the central
squares became public.
The later ones, the 18th
and 19th century ones
were public, generally.
It's an extraordinarily
formal device.
So when we look at four examples
of the residential squares,
you'll see the subtle
ways in which all of them
try to play around
with certain ideas--
the use of the road,
the use of monument,
the garden, the position of
the manor house, and so on.
The Mews of London were
the servant quarters
of these great estates.
Do you know the
word mews, M-E-W-S?
They're some of the most
expensive real estate in London
today.
They were the servant quarters.
It's only the wealthy
who can afford to live
in previous servant quarters.
It's another rule which
you might remember.
If land becomes valuable
enough, small space,
which is allocated appropriately
to the workers, working class,
becomes wealthy enough to
become the sole propriety
of a wealthy family.
When we talk about
Paris on Thursday,
you'll see the use of the public
square in Paris, the Place
Royale, for instance, at the
beginning of the 17th century.
Now-- then, later, renamed
the Place des Vosges--
was really the antecedent
of the Covent Garden plan.
The Covent Garden plan
had an empty center, which
was then occupied by a market.
The Place Royale was the house--
the residential environment
surrounding the Place Royale
was for the French aristocracy
and the royal court.
The French never followed
the residential subdivision
of the British pattern.
And many people,
including Rasmussen--
London, the unique city--
have commented on the fact
that London has always
been a series of small
endeavors, short vistas.
There's no Main
Street in London.
There's no main
avenue in London.
There's no great
avenue connecting
major parts of the city, as was
the principle of subdivision
or spatial
organization in Paris.
In the early part
of the 19th century,
the Prince Regent and a very
slick architect developer
called John Nash hatched a plan.
The Crown owned Regent's
Park to the north.
And there was some
notion that you
might be able to connect the
Crown land with the crown
land on the south.
It took the making of a new
street to enable to do that.
Here, you have a beginning
of the sensibility of Paris.
Louis Napoleon, who became
the French King and the patron
of Baron Haussmann
from 1848 to 1870,
was in London at the time.
He also spent time in Boston.
Apparently, he made a drawing
of the future of London
in one of the
restaurants in Boston.
Regent Street has two
major qualities about it.
Number one, it was able to be
the only spatial feature which
was able to be made in
London despite the edict
that London property should
remain in the hands of whoever
owned it unless bought.
You needed four qualities
to build a new street.
You needed an individual
who had the energy
to push the scheme
through, a good route,
an act of Parliament, and
about a million pounds.
The Prince Regent and Nash had
the authority and the money
to do this.
The merchants of this street
is a phenomenon in itself.
We will examine that a
bit later in the class,
referring to the writings of
David Friedman on this subject.
It was contrary to the principle
of land division in England.
And it was possible,
through the genius of Nash
and his anomalous energy--
and there's an interesting
aspect to this street.
If you look between Oxford
Street and Portland Place,
there is something
called All Souls' Church.
Do you see it?
When you go to London, go and
look at All Souls' Church.
It's a piece of
architecture which
indicates a fundamental
principle of urbanism.
You cannot buy the property
over here or over here.
In order to make a street
run straight through,
and you have to create a bypass.
You design a circus in
front of the church,
a circus being a spherical
space, an open space,
in front of the church to
carry the flow of the road
through like this.
Do you understand the principle?
It's not a cosmic
idea, but it's an idea.
There aren't many cosmic
ideas in urbanism.
They're not in England.
They are small ideas.
London is, according to
somebody whom I quote--
I don't remember his
name or her name--
London is a city
of small realities.
There's another significant
feature of Regent Street.
Between 1840 and
1916, a man called
Charles Booth worked in London.
He wrote a book called Life and
Labour of the People of London.
It's 12 volumes, published
between 1891 and 1900.
What did Booth do?
He produced something
for the first time,
which if you know
something about urbanism,
would recognize immediately.
He made a map of poverty.
He made the first map
showing income on a plane.
What-- Oxford Street.
Booth's map indicates that there
are more poor people living
on this side of Regent
Street than on this side.
So what do you
use new roads for?
This is what Engels
observed in Manchester.
Roads can serve the purpose
of subdividing property.
Land on this side is much less
valuable than on that side.
This is where, by the way, Snow
did his experiments on cholera.
So we learned a number of these
very little micro attributes
of urbanism, small-scale things.
Major revenues on one side,
a major lack of revenue
on another side.
Regent Street is
carefully modulated
as Moses's highways were
in relation to land values.
You can't build a
public road straight
through expensive property.
Roads can be deviated.
Sometimes they create spatial
avenues of the great charm
by virtue of them
twisting around.
But the basic motivation is
not aesthetic, it's economic.
The other great--
have we got time?
OK.
In the required
reading for this class,
there was a piece which I
wrote about the instruments
of application in
the 19th century.
I won't have time
to go through them.
The first is the invention
of the [INAUDIBLE] payment
amortized building loan.
The second is the transformation
of the building union
and building guilds into a
permanent building society
for the lending of money.
The third is the transformation
of a pre-industrial guild
of builders into a 19th-century
organization started by Thomas
Cubitt at the age of 27.
He employed a permanent,
year-long labor
force as opposed to
day-long laborers
provided by guild workers.
He also could assume
economic risks
and forecast the
value of property.
He established what is
called the contracting gross.
In times of such enormous,
fluctuating economy,
it's difficult for
a large investor
to predict the cost of
what he would have to pay
at the end of the project.
Cubitt revolutionized this by
inventing the contracting gross
by saying to the queen, it
doesn't matter what happens.
It's going to take 12 years
to finish this project,
you have to pay $300 million
pounds at the end of 12 years.
This is before--
I mean, this is in a
time of economics--
well, economics is
a modern science.
It only dates, probably,
from about 1900.
So we have Ricardo, and Marx,
and people like that, Malthus,
who weren't much help in--
but Cubitt understood that
the profits he could make
by maintaining a labor force--
again, we have Marx's
notion of surplus value.
By having 1,000 workers, you
reap a share of the income.
And therefore, you
become very wealthy--
according to Marx, anyway.
And when you are
very wealthy, you
can take economic risks
because you know what
you can produce at what cost.
I've mentioned the
transformation from freehold
to leasehold.
The last of these
policy implications
is the introduction or
invention of deficit spending,
which I'll elaborate on more
when we talk about Paris.
Paris was the first to assume
that the right of the state
to private land was great,
was large, significant only
to be exceptionally
reversed by private owners.
Haussmann's property
development schemes
were schemes based on the
notion of deficit spending,
that the state could engage
in large amounts of capital
deficit on the
grounds that it was
improving the economic
condition of the site.
And the site would,
over time, pay back.
The fact that Haussmann's
borrowings only
was paid back in 1928, some
75 years after Haussmann
spent the money, is
something we'll debate
in next Thursday's class.
Let's look very quickly at
the idea of the railroad.
London was the first to
introduce a train system
into the compact center
of a city as urbanism.
1863, the first subway ran
from on the north eastwards,
from Paddington Station
past all of those stations,
to the last one on the
bend, Farringdon Street.
These were [INAUDIBLE]
conditions.
It was only a small
indentation in the Earth.
And the train ran
without any ventilation,
except from the sky.
It was enormously successful.
There were millions--
it ran from 1873 to 1890
regularly at
10-minute intervals.
And I think it carried
something like a million or 10
million people regularly.
In 1890, the deep, old tunnel
was reintroduced largely
by an American
financier, Mr. Sprague.
And that set the pattern for the
building of a complete subway
system, almost complete in 1900.
I saw an estimate
of what it would
cost for a contemporary city
to build this, the London
Underground system.
And there's not enough money,
not enough capital in the world
to pay for it.
Of course, that's
an exaggeration.
There is enough capital.
But it's beyond the
reach of any living city.
The British were very clever in
investing in the sewage system
and in the public
transportation system.
They coupled the
inner circumstances,
with various colored lines,
with the suburban system,
which connected to the
outside, as yet relatively
unbuilt villages and towns.
There's a lot of details to be
discussed around the building
of the subway systems.
There was enormous
costs involved
in getting some
of these stations.
For instance, one writer
suggested that he took--
yeah.
The London and
Birmingham railway,
from the Midlands to Lord
Southampton's Euston station--
the railroad failed to
persuade the bid for the estate
to allow it any further.
It took an army of
20,000 men to construct
and was probably the
largest public work ever
to be undertaken in the
whole history of man
with the possible exception
of the Great Wall of China.
Digging this underground
tunnel in order
that Euston could get
to Marylebone high road
and be part of the
central combination--
11 million passengers in
the first year, and so on.
To leave us time
to look at this,
I'm going to shorten the last
part of this investigation.
Let's simply say
one or two things.
From the provision of
housing for the poorer
part of the population
to the state
accepting some role, a
major role in its care,
it was a variety of moves,
largely through charity
and philanthropy.
There was the
Octavia Hill system.
There was philanthropy for 5%.
Everybody assumed
that philanthropy
had to provide a profit.
There was the
Octavia Hill system.
There were arguments that
the poor needed resuscitation
through avoiding alcohol,
through temperance
associations, through
teaching the Octavia Hill
system to teaching them
how to behave properly,
how to save money, how to be
proficient with their time--
in fact, how to be
modern citizens.
The British aristocracy
assumed that it
could do for Engels's
Manchester just
through its own generosity,
plus a 5% fee for Americans
who invested in some of these
philanthropic organizations.
In 1889, the London County
Council was established.
The London County Council
became the first state or city
organization for the planning
and maintenance of the built
city.
It was remarkable.
It employed the highest
level of professional skill
that it could find,
people who were
great architects
like James Stirling,
others worked for the
London County Council
before branching
off on their own.
The standard of public housing
has not been challenged.
In 1965, the London
County Council
was abolished by
Margaret Thatcher
and became the
Greater London Council
with a different position.
But the great years of
the London County Council,
a very left-wing organization--
one of the architects
who worked--
I remember flying
from the Far East
with this gentleman, who was a
well-known architect in London,
who told me of his first
week working in London County
Council, of being taken to a
pub on the Friday afternoon
and asked whether he
was a socialist or not.
And he had to pass the test by
answering a bunch of questions.
Are there any questions about
this incredibly brief survey
one of the world's great cities?
I apologize for doing
it in the only way I
can think of doing
it, and that's
to pick on some characteristics.
There are some very
good books and London.
Landlords to London
is a good book.
There are a number of
others for those of you
who want to examine the
thing in greater detail.
But let's discuss.
We're talking about 1824, 1830.
Engels is writing a
book in Manchester.
We're talking
about the Enclosure
Acts, all of the penalties
imposed on the emergent working
class.
Slowly, the emergent
working class
gains a foothold in
the British democracy
and sets off 100 years.
And the 100 years produces
all of these things--
the first railway train,
underground, the first building
bylaws, rescuing
and transforming
a city from a completely
different environment,
in some respects,
from the conditions
that Engels expressed in the
condition of the working class.
There was no central state.
Well, there were many things
that the Soviet revolution
offered which the British
government didn't offer.
But a completely
remarkable Renaissance--
and that with, as I repeat,
only the killing of 11 or 13
citizens over 125
years, 123 years,
from Peterloo to Bloody
Sunday in Northern Ireland.
I think it's a remarkable--
it's a remarkable story for
those interested in the effects
that good action and technology
can take on urban form.
Here's the Roman crossing
on the east towards what
became the city of London.
Here, the minimal
fortifications.
The monastery's located
on the outside ring,
close to the walls in
case there's some crisis.
The monastery can send its
people to maintain the wall.
Next.
The Fire, the devastation of
the eastern part of the city.
[INAUDIBLE] plan on the
top, the diagonalization
and the centralisation
of the Royal Exchange.
Evelyn's scheme or [INAUDIBLE]
scheme, neither of which
gained much mileage.
Next.
Five and two combined,
virtually, the west of London.
This is Mary Davis,
whom I spoke about.
I don't know who took
this picture of her.
Next.
This is the pattern of
estate subdivisions.
And see the big gap on the left?
It is the Crown Regent's Park.
And the north is the crown.
A figure ground pattern
of the west of London,
indicating the black squares
aerating this fabric.
And the condition
of Regent's Park
is drawing the line from
Regent's Park on the north
Regent Street,
finding its way down
to the crown
property on the west.
Next.
OK.
Here are four examples.
This is the original
square, 1631.
The [INAUDIBLE] and the
elevation of Inigo Jones
and the proposed arcades and
surrounding of the square.
The square has a large empty
center like the Place Royale.
And it's indicated in the first
of these four, up on the left.
St. James Square on the right,
you see the enclosed garden.
The entrances are
carefully selected.
There's a monument to end the
vista from two of the streets.
The Bedford square
on the top right,
1773, where you
get the manor house
in the center of the elevation.
Here, the street system
is not so carefully
considered in relation to
the design of the square.
And here, Belgrave
Square, now an attempt
to break the mold of
the Georgian square
by putting the manor houses
outside the main elevation,
in the four corners,
opening the square.
This is not a gated square.
This is now a public square,
although treed, secondary manor
houses in the center
of the facade.
Next.
Grosvenor Square on the
right, the manor house
with the gabled facade in
the center of the facade.
Next.
OK.
We could have many
more illustrations
of these squares, the whole idea
of being able to link the crown
property in Regent's
Park systematically
through to Green Park
in Buckingham Palace.
The number of intersecting
roads and the degree
of the difficulty
of purchasing what
was cheap land and property
on either sides of the road.
Next.
This is looking up, northwards,
to All Souls' Church.
What you see is that
spin-wheel of an arcade
to turn you to the northwest.
Next.
Booth's map-- here
is Regent Street
in the quadrant leading
to Piccadilly Circus.
Look at the black and gray areas
to the right of Regent Street,
and the almost totally dark
red environment on the left.
It's another one
of Booths mapping.
That's of pubs.
British [INAUDIBLE] gin until
they stopped drinking gin
and started drinking
tea are regarded as--
cited in one of the
demographies of London.
It's a startling map.
It's one of the first attempts
to connect social status
with built form.
Next.
A 4-by-1-and-1/2 square,
Sir Joseph Paxton,
after the Crystal Palace,
proposed an elevated walking
route around the
4-by-1-and-1/2-mile center
of the city.
You can see this, all the
railway lines from the north,
from Paddington to
King's Cross, serving
the north, industry to
north, and the three stations
on the south--
Waterloo, Victoria, and Charing
Cross, essentially serving.
And the British-- the
subway system in the center,
moving outwards and then
connecting to a suburban
railroad system, a remarkable
application of public
transportation
technology as early as--
prior to the 20th century.
Next.
Building the metropolitan line
on the left, the upper one,
crossing the River Thames
with the train on the left,
the embankment of
the sewage system
and the new sewer
lines on the right.
Next.
Marylebone and Euston
Street being the facades
of these great railway termini.
Now, the railway termini
were ambiguous in themselves.
They were urban manifestations
with pronounced facades,
and hotels, and enormous
formal energy expended in order
that you should penetrate
this railway station--
which, after all, is just
a technological feat,
just a train and a railway
line, and some toilets,
and ticket booths.
It doesn't require
[LAUGHS] this apparatus
in the front unless you're
conscious of the city.
I like a city which
pays attention
to places of public
significance,
even if it there's
only a toilet behind.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JULIAN BEINART: I
wish our airports
had some way of galvanizing
their presence in the city.
They are little
technological nightmares.
Next.
Charing Cross and St Pancras
Station being built. Next.
Behind this neoclassical
Victorian facade
lies the technological
enterprise.
This is Birmingham
on the right, which
was the largest single span
at the time in the world, St
Pancras on the left.
Next.
Attempts to indulge in this
internal space of the railway
station with the same grandeur
that the external facade
on the street has.
Next.
Victoria Station in England,
something of a market,
Munich being a taking
over of the center
of the station as a market.
Next.
Victoria Station
in Mumbai, designed
with the same atmospheric
aesthetic impulse
to pronounce itself as a
major monument in the city.
And then inside, the
social consequences
of poverty displaying itself.
These two images, this and
the technological center,
are interesting in themselves.
Next.
Here is another attribute
of the charity world.
This is a working--
a poor man's labor workstation
where people don't have work
and are just left to be
fed and looked after,
what the equivalent would be
today of a homeless shelter.
On the right is a new
charity-inspired labor station.
Now, instead of the
rough, random allocation
of people in space, everybody
is now subdivided into booths.
And God is Holy and God
is Right in the beams.
The technology and theology
are mixed together.
If you can make a
beautiful place,
God must be able to
be celebrated in it.
It's making of poverty
a religious artifact.
Next.
And the greatest manifestation
of the technology--
the technology in
the Crystal Palace
is without any
pertinence in the front.
There is no attempt
to make an entrance.
This is just a
space for thousands
of people to come and see what
the British are doing in India.
There are trees inside.
Next.
Modernism, modern
inventions are portrayed.
One wants to compare
this to 1893 in Chicago.
This was 1851.
50 years later, the same attempt
was attempted in Chicago.
And we'll compare the two.
Next.
That's the story of London, as
briefly as I can explain it.